on that
let me with one last question bring back
master oogway
the probably the most famous quote of
his right
with the yesterday's history tomorrow's
a mystery but today is a gift
that is why it is called the present
it's very beautiful although i would
have gone with
quit don't quit noodles don't noodles
i feel i feel like people need to know
way too much context
for that to make sense it's your
audience
to hell with context yep they they'll
figure it out well let me ask
what are you grateful for today
what is your present we've talked about
a lot of dark things but what do you
brings you joy to your heart that
i can't believe i'm lucky enough to have
this
no nyla and zeb uh my wife pia
um the fact that we've got our health
all the
the little things saying grace
after meals you're coming over for
friday night shabbat dinner so we'll say
we'll we'll bench together and say grace
it's important
to just like this bottle of water in
front of me
i made a point um
of just thinking about how wonderful it
is that there's a quenching bottle that
happens to be placed in front of me
because somebody cared yeah you know so
that small thing made a difference to me
um
i still have strength for the fight so
far
i think that's something i'm grateful
for i can't believe that i'm not
more beaten down after all of this
nonsense
um
i have the most interesting set of
friends
i really do i mean i'm not that rich
by monetary standards but if there were
friend billionaires forbes would be all
over my ass
um i just can't believe who i can talk
to you know at the drop of a hat
and i'm really grateful
i think this is the end of something
profound
and it's the beginning of whatever is
next
and whatever is next could be terminal
whatever's next could be amazing
whatever is next could be a return to
the horrors of the early 20th century
that doesn't manage to go totally
catastrophic but
you know takes hundreds of millions of
lives in the process
i'm grateful to having half of my life
in the rearview mirror
it maybe it took place in a bubble and
maybe it was unsustainable
but it was it was nice to be able to
move around the world without a mask
uh it was nice to be able to see a
little bit of the world even if it was
from a
a cot in a hostel in some country
um to fall in love absolutely
i mean it was a good life find the last
indian jewish girl left
who knew uh you're a lucky guy well let
me
just say actually there's something i
wanted to just say before you get to
that yes
i forgot to say something falling in
love with an intellectual collaborator
is a special thing that not everybody
gets a chance
to do like i think when i met pia i felt
deeply in love with her
all her normal characteristics and i
she and i had an antagonistic
relationship around uh
geometry and economics
and then weirdly you know just like in a
buddy picture where in the first
half of the film they hate each other um
the two fields like we're fighting with
each other cats and dogs and finally
you know the sexual tension clearly was
so so thick you could cut it with a
knife
and we came up with geometric
marginalism which is this other theory
not geometric unity
which allowed me to inhabit space
with somebody who i already knew
intimately and had fallen
in love with and to see the quality and
beauty of their mind and to play into
dance it's sort of the intellectual
version of the tango
one of the most romantic periods of my
life that doesn't fall into most
people's
experience there was a chance to see
something totally unexpected
haven't really had it since because she
doesn't want to revisit the material
but something i'm super grateful for
that's very particular and unique
you